but let's return now to the claims that
a Russian spy ship stopped at sites
around wind farms off the Scottish Coast
in order to gather intelligence the
former deputy chief of Defense staff so
Simon male joins us now Simon lovely to
see you this morning
um How concerned should we be about this
and more importantly is this a new
development have the Russians not done
this before they've done it for many
years as did the Soviets before them I
think it was different uh Neil is of
course the context uh when the Soviets
were doing the so-called trawlers all
over the North Sea they were doing
exactly the same job intelligence
checking out vulnerabilities gathering
information
Etc but we we knew that was a they were
clear and present danger there were
plans Etc and we hadn't invested so much
in undersea undersea vulnerabilities in
North energy and intelligence the new
thing of course is now we have a Russia
that's carrying out perfectly legitimate
some of it intelligence we do it as well
the Americans around Taiwan ourselves
Etc but but now we have Russia as as you
know a a potential genuine enemy me and
of course we've increased our
vulnerability
um just on what we're looking at at the
moment though the balaclavids you know
assault rifle carrying and individual I
mean the Russians are not hiding this
particularly well aren't they well
they're not really but they you know
it's the act of an unfriendly Nation to
turn your transmitters off yeah you know
that clearly says we're doing something
clandestine
um you know our capacity to to track
them is is often difficult we've got so
many assets out there
um but the reality is that because this
is of concern to all you know to Denmark
to Norway uh to Nato to the European
Union uh we will be having a reasonable
handle on this it just happens that
we've broken a story about this
particular one but as you say the fact
that you've got an armed person on board
just shows that they have a this this is
this is genuinely the act of an
unfriendly State going about its
business trying to trying to work out
our vulnerabilities as part of whatever
contingency plan Mr Putin maybe maybe
putting together if um if the worst came
to the worst I mean it it is incredibly
Brazen if nothing else but when we talk
about increasing our underwater
vulnerabilities what are we talking
about is it basically Communications
it's all a communication but it's sort
of a gas we saw the attack on North
stream one as you well remember Neil So
the these things which are you know
hugely efficient way of you know
transporting energy our vulnerability
were anything unpleasant to happen and
whether it's sabotage whether it's you
know somebody who does it we still
haven't we still haven't pinned the pin
the whatever the tail on that particular
donkey who was responsible for it but
the any break in either Communications
intelligence or or energy uh has an
instant impact and some of it can be
caused to be deniable of course of
course but can anything be done to stop
this sort of surveillance particularly
if it's taking place in international
waters
well you can share it you can let people
know you can diplomatically uh signal
that were people to do anything harmful
everybody else has vulnerabilities as
well um and as I say nato uh and the
headquarters at NATO will will have a
very very very firm handle on what's
going on uh and we will have our own
counter cyber plans but again it this is
where the context changes for many years
we assumed we could lay these cables
intelligence uh been in Communications
energy in a benign geopolitical
environment and that is absolutely no
longer the case do we have the needle
assets to be able to protect that that
infrastructure that the Navy has over
the past few years seen an awful lot of
ships yeah being retired from service I
I would argue not okay I think we do not
you know that a ship can only be in one
place at a time indeed uh and if you've
got a number this is just one example
there are many many the Russians have
always invested in these intelligence
gathering Maritime assets so to actually
track them make it very clear write them
off and actually begin to of course to
to also collect information on them does
require you to get quite quite close so
again this will be a NATO a NATO you
know allies will be involved in this
surveillance operation the Danes and all
regions
um the Dutch Etc all of us who have a
vested interest in in the area of the
North Sea and the Baltic you mentioned
earlier cyber and clearly you know with
the Russians Gathering intelligence the
Russians belligerents you know on the
Eastern Frontier of Europe I mean are
are we are we in essence in a war in all
but name right now I think many of us
would argue we are uh it's not a
shooting war and um the vulnerability is
often not just your Armed Forces they
are they are you know the things that
keep modern society moving hence of
course why Putin attacked all the um the
energy and the energy infrastructure of
Ukraine this attack this this ability to
bring you know normal society into a
halt by attacking all you know
Communications and the uh and the you
know all the Cyber control links is is a
is a real threat
um and you know Putin is to an extent
running out of options uh the Russian
approach you know historically is is to
you know signal here do something else
there raise the stakes escalate to
de-escalate Etc so it is difficult to
know what's going through the mindset of
Putin and his allies when they when they
confront the failures on the ground in
um in Ukraine at the moment and the
prospect of a Ukrainian
counter-offensive sometime in the spring
um well let's see what happens with that
counteroffental um so Samuel great to
have you in the studio this morning
thanks for being here